[Music]
all right let's go out to St Paul
Minnesota and talk to Jane Sweet Jane
what's
up um hi Dr Loney thanks for taking my
call of course how we doing I'm uh not
not too bad how about yourself not too
bad not too bad either not too bad
either what's up good good um I'm just
going to read my question because I'm
really nervous if that's okay of course
of course it is uh okay so my question
is actually twofold number one should I
be completely honest with my husband
during difficult conversations about our
sex life and number two how do I fix the
sexual side of my
marriage um um I have some context is
there cont there you go no let's just
answer it like that um yeah go ahead
okay okay so um we've been married for
almost 30 years and I do not feel sexual
desire for my husband um and with few
exceptions I really never have we're
best friends platonically but I've never
felt spontaneous or responsive sexual
desire um and I've tried prayer
counseling porn hormone level testing
religion ignoring the problem completely
meditation anti-depressants alcohol lots
and lots of Faking it and nothing has
worked so I'm worried about being 85
someday and feeling regret that I didn't
experience sexual connection and desire
um my husband has called me out several
times over the years for not being
sexually attracted to him and I lie and
deny it because I love him and I don't
want to hurt him but he obviously feels
it yeah um sometimes I I'll I'll answer
answer this in reverse order sometimes
we don't want to hurt people that we
love especially about a sensitive topic
like this and that so much of our
personal identity is wound up in it
right and
um we hedge the truth or we don't tell
them the full truth because we don't
want to hurt him and and that makes them
feel crazy because they feel that they
feel you're not in right they feel they
feel the gab if you will
relationally and um instead of giving
them a hard answer that we can fix or we
can solve or at least deal with once
it's on the table um we tell them no no
no no I'm I'm totally into you sexually
or I'm totally into moving or I'm
totally into how we're raising our kids
and they know something's not right so
they end up trying to fix it and solve
it and then they go crazy um so yes to
reverse
I don't see a path forward that doesn't
start with telling the truth the
question I would ask you is what about
your relationship has prohibited you for
30 years to not be able to tell the
truth I I think really just that I I
don't want to hurt his feelings um but
like in my house in my house my wife and
I know
that hurting feelings going through that
pain is the only path forward to
resolving whatever is on the table which
means not that we're not going to hurt
each other's feelings but we have to
create a context where it's okay to say
what's true and for whatever reason
either you have taken on a maternal role
with your husband it's your job is to
make sure he feels okay it's which is
different than I want to connect with
him um the second or the second is he's
created a world where it's not safe for
you to tell the truth in that house
I it's probably more the the first I
just don't I don't know maybe I'm afraid
of consequences of the conversation like
I I don't know I think over time he said
things like well you either feel it or
you don't um and and so it's almost like
if I follow that up by admitting it out
loud then it's like kind of game over in
his mind like I should have it or I
don't have it and if I don't have it
there's no fixing it that's that's the
impression I've always gotten and so
well that's I mean that's that's that's
somebody reaching out out of pain
because he's probably watched you try a
whole bunch of stuff
and in his mind he's not
enough right yeah and so it's easy to
come up with some simplistic that sounds
veryl like a politician well it's
because of this well no it's not there's
a lot of nuance there there's a lot of
stuff there and so um it sounds like you
you're asking for two
things you want to preserve this
marriage as it is with your quote
unquote best friend in the world and you
also don't want to be 90 and wonder what
it would have been like to have a
reckless wild sexually romantic
marriage right it's almost like if you
tell the truth you know this thing's
over or at least the illusion that the
fake thing y'all have had is
over right that's true so I don't know
if I need to I don't want to preserve
the fake thing anymore though yeah not
that's why I'm calling well it like I'm
never going to tell somebody to continue
to lie about something that's not
right okay I'll never tell them that
which means you got to deal with a hard
gnarly truth on the back end and that's
scary too it's been going on for three
decades let me ask you a hard question
what else have you not told him the
truth about you don't to hurt his
feelings because there's more than just
this
um I mean I guess there's just you know
normal marriage stuff I mean stuff that
annoys me
so stuff that annoys me and I I just
don't say anything because I think he
thinks it's part of his personality and
I I again don't I don't want to hurt him
I don't want to like squash who he is um
so you you've you've been to I don't
want to diagnose any go ahead well you
know you finish what you were gonna
say I I don't want to diagnose anyone
because that's your job or somebody
else's job but he has a lot of things
that I would consider ADHD is like um
you know Timeless overt talking
interrupting oversharing kind of a
verbal diarrhea you know type thing um
and it's you know it's like an
embarrassing feeling sometimes when
we're with other people and so I I avoid
being with other people with him over
the years not that you know we Hermits
or anything but um I don't
know so some of those things I've just
never I mean I maybe brought them up
very mildly I just always kind of back
off of them I I don't tell them how much
it's bothering me you know and what
effect it's out on
me I hate that for you and I hate that
for
him I really do but I feel like if I
tell him he's going to be like well then
you basically don't like anything about
me you know yeah but he deserved to have
had that conversation 30 freaking years
ago
Jane cuz he could have dumped something
different with his life and you could
have done something different with yours
or one of the this is anic data behind
closed doors is when I meet with people
with ADHD especially
couples what I often hear is my God this
person's bananas and it's tough to live
with and my god when they are plugged in
they're the greatest lover on planet
Earth but you haven't given y y'all I
mean jeez I often don't say this but
you've you've perpetu wh why have you
stayed in this what do you what did you
get out of
it I mean we get along no you don't you
do not Jane you don't you know why you
don't like him you don't like him he's a
kid to you he's your child he's an adult
son you don't like how he is in public
you don't think his jokes are funny you
think they're inappropriate he doesn't
he's L to stuff you're not attracted to
him you you don't want to sleep with him
he's not your friend he's he's like a
pet
right I'm just using your words give me
something
back no I
I I can't refute a lot of that I do find
him funny we're in sync he's a good dad
I mean like there's just a lot of things
that I do appreciate about him
where but you don't you don't like
him I don't like some of his behaviors I
didn't say I didn't like him but you
don't like him enough to tell him the
truth for three decades and and here's
here's all I'm saying um I'm not saying
he's perfect in any way and he's got a
lot of stuff to
change I'm speaking as a guy who
struggles with some of the things he
struggles with and I'm so blessed that I
had a wife sit down with me while she
was still my girlfriend and then early
on and then as we figured it out
later to just be honest with me about
how she was is experiencing
me and that I can't imagine waking up 30
years and knowing that most of the
romance in my life has been
fraudulent because I know what it's like
to go to bed at night thinking the whole
thing is your
fault and it's just I mean god dude it's
it's
it's so yes you have to tell the truth
period okay okay the second thing is is
I don't know a lot of intimacy I don't
know anyone that can experience deep
intim intimacy especially over
time with a
lie that's that's the big the secrets
are the
Gap and for you said you've never felt
sexually attracted to
him well I mean I did when we were
dating you know obviously not obviously
cuz I would have said obviously you've
told him the truth for 30 years and you
haven't done that are you do you find
yourself sexually ATT to other
people um no I mean it no
okay I mean if I see like a really
good-look guy am am I going to turn my
head well yeah I mean I'm human but not
like I'm pursuing other people or
anything no no I I I'm I'm is he is your
husband for 30 years so he's the be in
the brunt of the weight of your your
lack of like the gap between how sexual
you want to be and what actually
happening in real life but my question
is are you would you classify yourself
as as someone who is aexual just I'm not
into it or it just I I have gone through
this and this and this and this and I'm
not into it or I'm just not into it with
that
guy and there's a difference there
probably the second I think probably the
latter I so let's let's play this out
let's play this out you and him break up
tomorrow you just call
it and you immediately get
tender and you swipe right and some
other dude swipes right and yall meet up
do you think it would that would be the
that would be the Alchemy you've been
looking
for that there's somebody else out there
that you would feel rambunctiously
sexually attracted
to I don't no probably
not I guess I don't know I I have no
idea
I've not thought about that
honestly you have to have thought about
it some because you spent a lot of time
thinking about hit not be I mean it not
being him right or maybe maybe you have
at all I I just want it to be in our
marriage like I feel connected to him
on I'm connected to him we've been
together for almost 30 years right yeah
and
I I want to do the right thing here
finally maybe or not maybe I do want to
do the right right thing for for his
sake and for mine you know yeah um so
let's be real specific about your needs
what what are they if you had to if you
had to write down on paper here's my
sexual needs what are
they I want to be connected to him and
feel like he's connected to me you've
for 30 years you've not allowed him to
be connected to you so let's go deeper
than that like that's a that's an
amorphous answer right so that starts
with telling the truth but let's get
beneath that be very specific what are
you what are you missing you don't like
how he smells you don't like him without
a shirt on like what all that is
fine um I mean he's attractive don't get
me wrong it's not like you know either
one of us is I don't know there's no
like body issues or anything um I don't
know I I I need romance I guess a little
bit I
need
um you
know I guess Romance maybe is a starting
point and when somebody says romance
that often means um and I'm I'm I
normally I would just sit here and make
you like not I would make you go through
the motions of here I want to be
specific about the things I believe
would lead to
this erotic
attraction um and you've been through a
lot you've been through all the normal
things that people do when they Google
like hey what do I do
right but often those are tactics or
they are specifics or they are focused
on the ACT once the bedroom door closes
right and when somebody says romance
often what they mean is I need a
different
context I need my life to feel and look
different so that I can be erotic inside
this world that you and I are
co-creating okay does that sound right
or no
it does sound right but I don't know how
to I don't know what to do with
that um do you know what I'm saying like
how do I other than
being honest with
him that's that's step one
um here's the hard place you find
yourself you're going to have to sit
down to a man that you love that you've
spent probably more time with him in
your life life than you have without him
is that
fair yes and you're going to have to say
I haven't told you the truth for about
years okay and from that conversation
and it will be
devastating one because he's hurt you
for so long he didn't know he
was two the dishonesty this is going to
be a hard hard
path his world will be uneven he won't
be able to stand on the foundation that
he thought his life was and in a weird
way it'll be such a great
relief I've talked with couples before
that say things like I wish she would
just tell me she's cheating on me then I
wouldn't feel so
insane we'd have to deal with the
infidelity and I'd have to get a new
life and all that but God at least I
wouldn't be feel like I'm crazy and
so but when you do this have this
conversation you're going to have to be
specific about what has to happen in
this new marriage y'all have to build
because you're not going backwards to
when y'all were dating you're going to
have to decide we're going to build
something totally new and that's where
you have to be specific in this new
marriage here's what romance feels and
looks like to
me you're on you're on time to
things you help pick up the
kids there's never dishes in the sink
after I cook dinner you've got to go get
a job you have to quit drinking after
you know you see what I'm saying MH the
specifics and after 30 years he needs a
road map to your heart CU he's thought
he was there and he is
not okay that doesn't mean that this is
all going to fix your sexual dysfunction
it's going to give it a
chance
right the last question I have for you
is this do you
want to feel sexual desire or you want
to want to feel sexual desire towards
him and you get the difference in that
question no I'm not not entirely no I
would love to want to live in New York
City the energy the fun the constant
noise and in like the the like all of it
I'd love to want to do that it sounds
like it would be fun I don't my wife
would love to love my wife would love to
want to go to punk rock shows with
me they're too loud and I like mosh
pitting even though I'm old and she
doesn't like that
right that's that's step one the other
side of it that's not step one but
that's one side I want to want to live
in New York but I don't like
it I like nature and I like trees and I
like the woods and I like a slower Pace
okay it's why I like Texas it's why I
like Tennessee it's why I like Kentucky
I like some of these lower places okay
on the other side
um if you want
to like I want to get in shape well cool
then i' there's a thousand plans out
there to go get in shape I'm going to
follow one of those plans and the shape
part will take will happen does that
make
sense yeah it does so which one do which
where do you find
yourself do you just want to want to be
romantically attracted to him this just
not going to happen or no I want to I'm
going to deal with this hard stuff and
then we're going to go try to make that
happen no I want to okay all right that
at least tells me you'll have a chance
okay otherwise your honesty conversation
is totally
different
okay
okay and can I ask you one more question
before we go sure when you met with a
therapist they didn't tell you
this um
I mean they didn't say you got to be
honest and tell the
truth I I think they were playing off of
my reluctance maybe or just giving into
my reluctance to be honest maybe I I
know not in that not in that
straightforward manner no one said that
to me
no I'm sorry man you got really bad bad
support and
care it's brutal
dude
if I'm M here's how I would start the
conversation I would say we have to have
a hard conversation it's going to take a
few hours and it's going to be tough for
you to process and I haven't cheated on
you the marriage isn't over so I didn't
do I didn't spend a million dollar
like and also I want to be married to
you I want to love you the best I can
and I want to give you a road map to
love me and for 30 years I've withheld
that road map and I'm sorry and in fact
I'm still figuring out what it
is but there can be no intimacy there
can be no new marriage there can be no
relationship without me without me first
being honest with you so we're going to
start we're going to re repour the
foundation today and it's with honesty
and I'm going to go
first and then he may need silence he
may need a week he may need what who
knows what he'll need but I want you to
be gracious enough and give it to him
and he's going to come back with a bunch
of questions he's going to first think
what else have you lied about what else
this what be prepared for all that and
be prepared to say in this new marriage
I want to
build here's some things I'm going to
need so that we can build an erotic
ethos in this home a home that pulses
with romance that pulses with desire and
that starts with us building something
totally
new and for everybody listening for
God's sakes you have to tell the truth
in your marriage period even when it's
hard especially when it's
hard lying never solves a thing in a
marriage